hi everyone I'm Lin Clark and I make
Coke cartoons and I also work at Mozilla
on things like webassembly which I gave
a talk about last year here at Jay has
come for you in fact that was what was
featured on there and this talk is about
webassembly too but this is a different
kind of talk from last year's talk I
think you've all probably seen this
structure by now it's kind of hard to
miss right in the middle there but you
may have wondered what it was doing it's
playing animations created by all of you
but why why did we want to do this well
one of the hardest problems when you're
learning a new programming language is
figuring out a project that you can work
on one that will teach you the basics of
the programming language but still keep
you interested enough to keep learning
more because there are only so many
times they can implement HelloWorld in a
new language and have it be interesting
at all because your hello world has no
real-world impact but what if your hello
world could have an impact on the real
world what if your hello world could
control a structure like this one and
that's exactly what you can do your
hello world can play a light animation
on the space out there now some of these
animations are made with JavaScript and
if you're here you might not be too
interested in a JavaScript hello world
but some of the animations are made in a
language that you may be interested in
learning and that's rust compiled to web
assembly so you'll be coming away from
jeaious convey you with lots of new
friends and lots of new experiences and
I hope that one of those new experiences
is your first rust module compiled to
web assembly so let's get started on
baby's first rust - web assembly module
and this is kind of the perfect project
for that not because this is the kind of
project that you would usually use web
assembly for people use web assembly
because they want to supercharge their
application and make it run faster or
because they want to use the same
on the web and other platforms this
project doesn't do either of those we
create these animations ahead of time so
we don't care about having consistent
high performance and we don't need to
run on any other devices so we don't
need it to be portable the reason that
this is a good project for getting
started with web assembly is not because
this is what you usually use web
assembly for instead it's because it's
really useful in giving you a mental
model of how javascript and web assembly
work together so let's take a look at
what we need to do to take control of
this space with web assembly and then
I'll explain what makes a good mental
model for how web assembly and
JavaScript work together what we have
here is a three dimensional space and
really if you think about it it's
actually a four dimensional space
because we're going through time as well
the computer can't think in these four
dimensions so so how do we make these
four dimensions make sense to the
computer let's start with the fourth
dimension and collapse down from there
you're probably familiar with the way
that we make time the fourth dimension
makes sense to computers that's by using
these things called frames on the web we
talk about having 60 frames per second
that's what you need to have smooth
animations across the screen what that
really means is that you have 60
different snapshots of the screen of
what the animation should look like at
60 different moments in that second it's
kind of like a flipbook and each frame
is like a page in that flip book in our
case the snapshot is a snapshot of what
the lights on the space should look like
and our frame rate for that is 35 frames
per second so that brings us down to a
sequence of snapshots of the space a
sequence of 3d representations of the
space now we want to go from 3d to 2d
and in this case it's pretty easy all we
need to do is take the space and flatten
it out into basically a big sheet of
graph paper
so now we're down to 2d we just need to
collapse this one more time the way we
can do that is by taking each row and
putting that row next to the previous
row so now we're down to this line of
pixels and we can put this in memory
because memory is basically just the
line of boxes so this means that we've
gotten it down to a one dimensional
representation we still have all of the
data that we had in the two or the three
year the four dimensional representation
of this space is just being represented
in a different way it's being
represented as a line the reason that
this is a good mental model for how web
assembly and JavaScript work together is
because one of the main ways to
communicate between web assembly and
JavaScript at the moment is through
something called linear memory it's
basically a line of memory that you use
to represent things the web assembly
module and the JavaScript that's running
that module both have access to this
object through a JavaScript object
called an array buffer and this is just
an array of bytes and bytes are just
numbers so to make this animation happen
JavaScript tells the web assembly module
okay fill in the animation now and it
does this by calling a method or a
function on the web assembly module web
assembly will go and fill in all of the
numbers for each pixel in the linear
memory and then JavaScript code can pull
those numbers out and serialize them
into something that can be sent to the
space let's look more closely at the
JavaScript side of things let's see how
it pulls data out of the memory and uses
it if you're getting into the
nitty-gritty of this if you're doing
things the hard way and not using any
libraries then you're going to be
working directly with this linear memory
and this linear memory is just one big
line of ones and zeroes when you want to
create meaning from this line of ones
and zeroes you have to figure out how to
split them up to do this you create a
typed array view on the array buffer and
basically this just tells JavaScript how
to break up the bits in this array
buffer it's basically like drawing boxes
around the biz to say which bits belong
to which number for example if you are
using hexadecimal values then your
numbers would be 42 bits wide so you
need a box that could fit at least 40
sorry if you're using hexadecimal values
than your numbers where you 24 bits wide
so you need a box that can fit at least
24 bits and each box would contain a
pixel the smallest box that fits those
24 bits is 32 bits wide so we would
create au inch 32 view on the buffer and
that would wrap the bits up in boxes in
this case we'd have to add a little
padding to fill it out I'm not showing
that but there would be some extra zeros
in here in contrast if we use RGB values
the boxes would only be 8 bits wide and
we would take every three boxes and use
those as our our G and B values then you
would iterate over the boxes and pull
out the numbers and move the data around
insist more sensible data structures for
a project like this that's not too bad
because because colors map very well to
numbers and we don't have very complex
data structures here we just have the
our G and the B but when you start
getting more complex data structures
having to deal with memory this directly
can be a big pain the reason that you
have to deal with memory so directly
with webassembly right now the reason
that you can't just pass an object from
JavaScript into web assembly and have
web assembly changed properties and
values on it and then give that object
back is because webassembly doesn't yet
have direct access to JavaScript objects
or the Dom that is in the works the web
assembly community group is working on
specifying that but just because that
isn't here yet that doesn't mean that
you have to wait before you can start
working with objects you don't have to
wait you can pass objects into your web
assembly and get objects back from your
JavaScript to do this you can use a
library that gives you this nicer API
this library is called wasm bind gen
it wraps the web assembly module in a
JavaScript wrapper and this wrapper
knows how to take complex JavaScript
objects and write them into linear
memory and when the web assembly
function returns a value the j/s wrapper
can take data from linear memory and
turn it back into a json jacked to do
this it looks at function signatures in
your rust code and figures out exactly
what kind of javascript wrapper is
needed
this works for built-in types like
strings and it also works for types that
you define in your code wise and bind
gen will take the RUS trucks and turn
them into JavaScript object classes
right now this tool is specific to rust
but with the way that it's architected
we can add support for this kind of
higher-level interaction for other
languages languages like C and C++
there's a session that will cover the
basics of rust and some of these other
topics likewise some bind gen and woz
impac which you can use to package up
your wasm modules to go up on NPM and
this session will be tomorrow at the
Mozilla booth starting at 13:30 at 1:30
p.m. so hopefully now you can see how to
take control of this space and how you
can say hello to the world and hello to
the world of web assembly before I wrap
this up I do want to give credit to the
people that made this project possible
the seeds for the idea of this product
it came from a dance party that I
attended in Pittsburgh that had a space
like this but the project was only
possible because of the amazing group of
people that gathered to make it a
reality
so I want to say thank you to Sandra /
sing I came to her with a vision and she
made that vision real I want to also
want to say thank you to Dan Brown and
Matt's a Pluto who took that vision and
turned it into something even more
exciting and engaging than I imagined
until Schneider Wright who helped me
figure out how to bring all of these
different pieces together
Josh Mira naxi who created the site and
made taking control of the space
possible dan Callahan who you also saw
in that video he jumped in with his
debugging and development wizardry to
ensure all of the pieces work together
Trevor F Smith who created the virtual
space so that everybody can experience
this even if they aren't here at the
event also Michel Bonita and URI delenn
Dec whose work on webassembly studio
makes it possible to share webassembly
with the whole new audience row stations
Alex Kryten Ashley Williams Sarah Myers
Jana Jana our creditor fluorine gilt
receive clap Nick Fabian and flock e who
worked on webassembly studios rust
integration helped aspiring Russ
developers level up their skills the J's
confit you team for all of their hard
work in making sure that this
installation get off the ground and of
course umbral the artist whose work
inspired this project and she's
hard-working sure that we could share it
with you thank you and Alice party
[Applause]